all Pixar movies take a long time to
develop even by Hollywood standards the
studio spends years building their
lavishly rendered stories but even for
Pixar the journey Coco took from idea to
Blockbuster was a rather lengthy one so
what took so long
what changed and how did we arrive at
the film we now know and love Day of the
Dead co-director Lee Unkrich was fresh
off the triumph of Toy Story 3 when the
idea for Coco came to him at Walt Disney
World of all places
according to Unkrich he was in the
middle of a boat ride at Epcot's Mexico
pavilion when he saw an image that
ignited a spark of inspiration he
recalled
we passed a mariachi skeleton band and
that was my trigger moment I started to
think about the potential of telling a
story set against the culture of Mexico
I had never seen a full story told
against Dia de los Muertos Pixar
approved the project and encouraged
started moving forward but Coco was
different from other Pixar productions
encouraged said when I did Toy Story 3
we settled on a few basic ideas that
were going to be part of the film and of
course we had most of our characters
already set in the look of the world in
this case we had nothing I mean we just
had a blank piece of paper and that was
it public backlash though Coco is very
heavily rooted in Mexican culture it
began as the brainchild of a white
director who had a deep desire to ensure
its authenticity those efforts took a
turn toward PR nightmare in 2013 when
Disney attempted to trademark the phrase
Dia de los Muertos the one night of the
year our ancestors can come visit us
prominent Latinos including cartoonist
Lalo alcaraz saw it as a cold attempt by
an American corporation to appropriate a
cornerstone of Mexican culture and they
were outspoken in their criticism the
backlash prompted Pixar to relax it's
usually rather secretive production
process and hire several Latino cultural
consultants to work on the film
including alcaraz who said Pixar was
already on its way to making this a
culturally authentic film and we met
somewhere in the middle and even though
I'm not very corporate they listened to
what I had to say
the consultants provided input on every
phase of the production process from
character designs all the way through to
test screenings looming finality after
getting the green light to pursue his
idea encouraged and the production team
began a thorough research process in a
temp to absorb every detail about the
day of the dead it was then that they
came across the idea of final death the
notion that you die in the mortal world
and die again in the afterlife when your
memory in the land of living is finally
extinguished
according to Unkrich this film defining
idea was initially just a small part of
the story at the time we learned about
it we thought it was a poignant idea and
it was something we wanted in the movie
but after some time we came to the
realization that no that's the idea of
the movie which needed to permeate
everything in the film secrets of the
shrine one of the most important moments
in the film comes when Miguel retreats
into a little hideaway he's built for
himself where he can secretly indulge in
his true musical passions the tiny room
functions as a miniature shrine to his
musical Idol Ernesto de la Cruz
featuring photos and albums
Miguel's own battered guitar and a small
TV where Miguel can play a video
compilation he's made of key de la Cruz
moments it's a vital scene because it
reveals just how serious Miguel is about
music the clearest inspiration for the
scene may have come from co-director
Adrian Molina's own childhood dreams of
being an animator Melina recalled
watching tape reruns of the wonderful
world of color on the Disney Channel
these episodes would rerun at 4:00 a.m.
and I remember waking up every morning
sticking in a video cassette and
crossing my fingers that it would record
one of the episodes where they would
talk about how a film was animated like
miguel molina cherished every snippet of
his heroes he could scrape together and
that made its way into the movie as for
a shoeshine that's your life story y
Coco if you're approaching Coco for the
first time you might spend a good bit of
the film a bit confused over the title
its namesake Miguel's great-grandmother
is revealed fairly early on but her
significance to the plot is unclear
until much later when the name takes on
a great emotional weight but for much of
the production process it was used only
as a placeholder a working title for the
filmmakers until they came up with a
better one encouraged revealed we didn't
know what we were going to call the film
for a very long time we made lists of
hundreds of different titles to try and
figure out what it could be Coco was
always just kind of a code name
Pixar innovation each Pixar film
presents an opportunity for a potential
new first in the field of animation and
Coco is no exception the numerous
skeletons in the film
presented several challenges which
became a problem when animators realized
their software wasn't up to the task
when clothing was placed on the
skeletons in the old program it didn't
react properly and would get pinched and
tangled between bones as a result Pixar
spent three years revamping its software
to accommodate the film specifically
focusing on how their animated objects
would interact by the time they were
done the skeletons didn't just wear
clothes they wore them tight against
their ribs just like real walking
talking skeletons might
[Music]